welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies games TV shows and
comics throughout this video we're going
to be going over everything that you
need to know about the ending of the new
Netflix movie rattlesnake there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the film yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
rattlesnake rattlesnake follows Katrina
and her daughter Clara on a road trip to
Oklahoma to get away from what we can
determine is an unhappy life due to the
self-help tapes that she is listening to
Katrina instills in a daughter that she
shouldn't hurt anyone ever but this
moral standing comes into question
throughout the movie when the character
is required to do so in order to repay
her debt
rattlesnake wastes no time getting to
the point of its paw aesthetic and after
Clara is bitten by a rattlesnake on the
road the movie quickly kicks it up a
notch
Clara is basically at death's door due
to the bite and it seems like Katrina is
going to watch her daughter die in front
of her until she comes across a trailer
on the road that houses a mysterious
woman miraculously the woman is able to
heal Clara of the wrath snakebite and
the wound completely disappears Katrina
takes her to a hospital in Tulia and not
long after but the wound is brushed to
the side with her fever being chalked up
to dehydration or exhaustion
however we learn that a high cost comes
with a doors miraculous recovery
and after Katrina is visited by a
mysterious man at the hospital he
demands payment for Clara's change of
health and states that Katrina must take
the life of someone else in order to
clear the debt it's a soul for a soul
but Katrina isn't exactly Thanos and she
struggles to deal with the fact that in
order to save her daughter's life she
must take another rattlesnake is a
really high concept horror and in the
wake of Eli wounds and Netflix's more
recent entries it sits nicely on the
platform is an intriguing film that will
definitely have you grip from the
prospect of the plot points that it
portrays this is due to the acting and
the fact that Carmen ejogo who plays
Katrina is a highly relatable character
even as a single middle-aged mother
tried to escape her past viewers are
still able to put themselves in the
position of
character who has been tasked with this
impossible decision we learned that the
soul has to be human and that it has to
be paid in full and on time
Katrina has until sunset to clear the
debt and the mysterious man demonstrates
exactly what will happen if she doesn't
make good on the payment Katrina
desperate for answers drives back out to
the desert road but the trailer has
disappeared and after running into an
angry trucker that is heavily wounded
and has a missing eye she begins to
believe that this is more than just a
trick
rattlesnake feels akin to old episodes
of The Twilight Zone and fans of the
show will definitely find a lot to like
here the town just has an atmosphere
about it and every time a horror movie
is set around Texas you really get the
broad scape of the state with the vast
stretching desert and almost mirage
inducing surroundings it's one of
rattlesnakes strong points and we learn
that Tulia itself as a location is just
as haunting as the characters that
Katrina runs into we discovered that the
town has been linked to a number of
brutal murders and disappearances and
every bit of evidence that Katrina can
unearth shows a mysterious figure in the
background in addition to this many of
the people that have been victims of the
slayings are those that Katrina has run
into including a lawyer a child that
scares her and the trucker this is
because those taken by the curse are
brought into it and become a form of the
shadowy figure behind it all the
specters themselves act as reminders
that Katrina is running out of time and
must act in order to save her child in
addition to this they are four still
about their deaths over and over such as
the little boy that smashes his head
into Katrina's car window the priest
that is set on fire and so on from this
we can guess a to Lia is actually limbo
in some form or another a purgatory that
forces all the souls taken there as part
of the curse to remain in the area
trapped in the vicious cycle this
mirrors Katrina who is attempting to
escape from a circle of toxicity back
home and in doing so she is forced into
another one and the movie can actually
be viewed as a metaphor for people who
wish to escape a negative lifestyle and
sometimes the ends that they have to go
to in order to do it whilst most just
cut people out of their lives
Katrina has to cut them literally and
it's a movie that can definitely be
applied to real life when viewed through
this lens however this is a horror and
Katrina has made a deal with the devil
in order to save her daughter and time
is running out Katrina knows what she
has to do and after know
seeing a man whose days were numbered
earlier in the movie she begins to make
her play
Katrina has a change of heart though and
doesn't want to rob the family of their
last few minutes with their father and
when he dies of natural causes she
realizes that she has to come up with a
new plan
thus she sets her sights on Billy a
violent and aggressive man played by
Thea Rossi who she determines has to die
because he is abusive to his girlfriend
there is a lip service paid to the fact
that Billy's girlfriend is the
definition of insanity due to the fact
that she is stuck in a vicious cycle
with him and when Katrina sneaks into
their home she discovers that this will
continue for the character this harkens
back to the prior point and just in the
same way that Katrina wants to free
herself she also recognizes the cycle in
others and wishes to get them out of it
even though she will ultimately force
one more person to end up in their own
personal hell Katrina kidnaps Billy at
gunpoint and drives him into the desert
to a remote canyon where he manages to
escape after coming face-to-face with
another ghost
Katrina realizes that she has no other
option but to kill herself she films a
goodbye message but Billy reappears and
hits her with a rock
luckily for Katrina the titular
rattlesnake appears once more and bites
belly which sends him over a cliff easy
prey Katrina climbs down and kills him
whilst he screams that she will burn in
hell for this the Sun Goes Down and we
see some of the figures from earlier in
the movie watching her and Katrina
leaves the canyon and on her way back to
the hospital receives a call from them
which says that Cora is fine however
when Katrina arrives there she sees that
Clara has drawn a picture of the
mysterious figure to me this indicates
that she is somewhat aware of what her
mother has had to do and the curse that
she was part of the to leave the town
and on their way out they see Billy
hitchhiking now part of the curse and
unable to leave the town and the vicious
cycle that he is trapped in juxtaposing
this Katrina and Clara have managed to
escape and will hopefully go into a
better life with each other now the
title itself for me refers to the fact
that in this land the rattlesnake is
basically the devil similar to the form
that he took in the Garden of Eden
Lucifer is a snake that wishes to ten
people with a promise of something
better but in exchange he demands the
sacrifice the snake wishes to have more
Souls and we can determine from the
action that it takes towards the end
that the more corrupt the soul are
better this is because when Billy has
Katrina held up
snake intervenes in order to save her
and it was likely weighing of the two
options determining that belly was the
more corrupt an evil person and
therefore his soul was worth more the
snake will likely remain at the border
of the city catching our souls that
enter into his realm and trapping them
into a deal with him we know from the
ghost that this has already happened
numerous times and now that the
rattlesnake will continue to do its job
of collecting Souls in the area but what
did I think of the film overall well
rattlesnake has been receiving mixed
reviews across the board but I actually
quite enjoyed it I love films like this
that put characters into desperate
situations where they are forced to
commit evil in order to carry out a good
act and though rattlesnake has a rather
small scope in terms of location and
cast it actually does quite a lot with
it there's a lot of allegories here with
the main one being that in order to get
the rainbow sometimes you have to go
through the rain and the film is a nice
enjoyable horror that has arrived just
in time for Halloween it doesn't rely on
jump scares or cheap tactics to get its
point across and instead the most
sinister side of the movie is the
meaning behind it and the deeds that
Katrina has to carry out in order to get
her daughter back as mentioned earlier
this gave me Twilight Zone episode vibes
and I can easily imagine this piece
fitting in amongst those entries as an
unnerving twist on society that has a
supernatural element to it rattlesnake
is a fun watch and I can see why netflix
are listing it above the pretty middling
daybreak this week as out the two titles
this is by far the better one though it
isn't perfect it's still an enjoyable
journey that in my opinion could have
probably done with chopping ten minutes
off here and there but overall it's a
great little horror to sink your teeth
into if you just want something that you
can put on sit back with and relax
I enjoyed rattlesnake on the hole and
that's why it gets a six point five out
of ten now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on rattlesnake and what
you took from the movie comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of last week's big Netflix Horror eli
which would be linked at the end we go
over everything that you need to know
about the movie and its final few scenes
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me in Twitter after
finishing my tea or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 pot one boxer blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on rattlesnake in the
comments section below the one it's
gonna be chosen on the 15th of November
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever get to the prize it's a
best of luck that everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
were mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]